there was a tweet that i saw somewhere
during the 2020 draft pointing out that
historically there are more undrafted
players in the hall of fame than number
one overall picks in the hall of fame
and uh it's fairly obvious when you
think about it because there's only one
number one overall pick per year there
are hundreds of undrafted players and
some of those guys do indeed make it to
camp so today's draft is the best
undrafted players of all time big cat
gets the trivia question here we go big
cat who is the only quarterback in nfl
history to start a season eight and oh
and start a season oh and eight
and the hint is that he currently
uh is uh oh it's anything in the league
there you go
i was trying to think out best of i was
trying i was trying to think of how best
uh to phrase the tint because he's in
the league but he's not in the league
and i don't want to say that because it
would either be him or cam newton but uh
you got it right you got andy dalton you
get the first pick in the craft of the
best undrafted players of all time the
first pick is an easy one for me
it's going to be
kurt warner and i think you have to go
with the hall of famer to start and kurt
warner i actually we recently on part of
my take shameless plug did our top uh 10
qb's of all time
and i i regret not at least saying kurt
warner because kurt warner was that good
at his peak
the you know greatest show on turf kind
of revolutionized with what offensive
football looked like at the time that
was something totally new had a complete
second act with the cardinals
when kurt warner was on it was tough to
to top him in terms of the quarterback
play he was an undrafted free agent
obviously everyone knows stocking shells
at a grocery store playing arena
football unbelievable story kurt warner
is my number one undrafted free agent
especially because we'll see other guys
on this list but doing it from the
quarterback position
you know how how much we value it and
how many resources get put into it to
have an undrafted hall of fame
quarterback is quite the feat so kurt
warner is my number one
and i i remember the way that kurt
warner kind of landed on the radar
screen trent green took a low hit from
rodney harrison in a pre-season game in
1999 dick for meal literally cried about
it and you just wrote the rams off at
that point i mean the rams had been bad
who's this kurt warner guy they're not
going to be any good and then the next
thing you know
it just it just it's one of those
moments where as it's happening you know
it's really really special and it's
going to be memorable and you can sense
it a lot of times you need the benefit
of of time and distance to appreciate
what you saw that was one of those
almost like the 85 bears to give your
your team a little pop where you know as
it's happening this is a big deal this
is special and it made it more special
that we're hearing about we're learning
about this guy who played for the iowa
barnstormers he played in the world lake
and who the hell is this guy he's a guy
who you know by the way i think it was
paul burmeister of nbc that got kurt
warner's scholarship to iowa he had to
go to some school other than iowa
northern iowa or something like that
so many little wrinkles and they're
going to make the kurt warner movie the
kurt warner movie is coming so we'll
learn all about kurt warner yes
yes are you gonna get a cameo
no
no are you
no
why would i
i don't know why would i all right i
don't know first pick for me and i'm
glad you got the trivia question right
because i was going to struggle with
this because kurt warner is the obvious
choice for anybody who's been paying
attention to football for the past 30
years but as i did my research for this
i was reminded and the kids out there
who are currently playing madden if
you're playing the ultimate team on
madden you know who this guy is because
he is one of the best players in the
game dick knight train lane who was
undrafted in 1952 now you'll say well
there was only like 12 teams in the
league then who who cares if you're
undrafted there were 30 rounds of the
draft in 1952.
360 players were drafted that year and
not one of them was knight train lane
and knight train lane had 14
interceptions as a rookie that's still
the single season record for
interceptions today
he made it to the hall of fame undrafted
with 360 guys selected by 12 teams in
1952 so and that's i would have really
struggled between him and kurt warner
because as you learn more about dick
knight train lane it's amazing that the
guy made it it's amazing that he's in
the hall of fame it's amazing he wasn't
drafted
that is incredible 30 rounds oh my gosh
that's that's awesome um
good pick but it's way too old for
people to think that was a good pick but
i know it's a good pick mike even though
it's not a great pick okay
listen if you were playing if you were
playing madden instead of that old
college football game from 1998
that you're streaming on twitch every
day you would know who dick knight train
lane is instead of who this doug this
coach doug's guy is coach doug's the
legend in the game is from 2014. not
that old i can't believe you didn't pick
this guy though oh with my second pick
i'll go to your team
how did you not take john randle john
randall
what what i was hoping you wouldn't
of course i'm gonna take john randall he
was number two on my board john randall
uh one of the best defensive tackles in
in in the nfl in the 90s 137 and a half
sacks in his career undrafted and of
course the cool eye paint that he would
put on john randall absolutely deserves
to be on this list of best undrafted
free agents played for the minnesota
vikings wasn't able to win a ring with
that team that was fantastic 15-1 they
missed a field goal uh late in the game
against the falcons the falcons go to
the super bowl they probably should have
won the super bowl that year but john
randall is my number two pick
now you just said and we can play it
back if we need to that quarterbacks get
extra
preference in this regard because it's
an important position and it's a more
important no no no no no
quarterback that's what you said
i already have a quarterback it's called
diversifying your portfolio my friend
all right
because uh you overlooked an undrafted
quarterback a quarterback
i know she's i didn't know him yeah
warren moon give me one minute well then
why didn't you take him why didn't you
take him i thought you would take him
john randle i wanted to take a viking
yeah i wanted to take a viking well
warren moon played for the vikings you
realize that don't you that's you but i
wanted to take a mr viking
that's what i'm calling
warren moon played for the vikings in an
era where they routinely dominated the
chicago bears that's probably why you
didn't take warren
but you think hold on if you think of
warren moon you think houston oilers
yeah oh absolutely okay absolutely yeah
all right all right i'm just making sure
i knew he played the vikings but i'm
saying he was a houston oiler like that
would be the the team you'd think of
yeah but still warren moon unbelievable
that he wasn't drafted
consciously went to canada instead of
trying to make it as an undrafted guy in
the nfl became a star in canada and
finally got his chance in the nfl and
made a lot of people look stupid for not
giving him a chance from the get-go one
of the great quarterbacks of all time so
without question warren moon all right
what do you got next all right i'm gonna
continue to diversify my portfolio here
with my last pick and that will be out
of kent state antonio gates antonio
gates one of the best tight ends of all
time unbelievable career 16 seasons uh
obviously everyone knows he was a
basketball player
it was it's crazy i still think that
antonio gates is going to be there week
one i don't know if he actually is
retired or not but he is bound for the
hall of fame and that will give me now a
uh defensive player a tight end and a
quarterback that is a dominating draft
by me
good job big cat
all right i've got a defensive back who
has the single season record for
uh
interceptions all time i've got a
quarterback who probably has thrown for
more yards than anyone if you put
together his nfl and cfl numbers now i
have a lot of different ways i can go
here i thought about wes welker
uh because i was surprised to remember
that he was undrafted but he didn't have
a hall of fame career so wes welker
doesn't get the nod
sorry wes james harrison i thought about
him he's not going to be a hall of famer
either great player undrafted cut like
15 times before it finally worked for
him i admire that kind of perseverance
but again he's not going to be a guy i
think at this point who gets to the hall
of fame the one hall of famer out there
that i can't overlook
is uh
boy i'm torn i'm torn between willie
brown and donnie shell i got to give it
to willy brown even though i'm still
upset about the slow motion nfl films
highlight highlighted the interception
return against the vikings in super bowl
11. i got to go with donnie shell i not
no i got to go with willy brown i
thought about donnie shell because he
was undrafted in the year that the
steelers drafted four hall of famers and
now shells making it to the hall of fame
willie brown
a half click above donny's show so i'm
trying to wedge him both in to my to my
pick here but i'll take willy brown uh
as my last one undrafted by the raiders
and an all-time legend so uh it was fun
it was fun any other names that didn't
make your car yeah
yeah the a couple other names i had
floating around priest holmes uh tony
romo
and then this one is a little bit
different because they don't usually
draft these guys but adam vinitari was
undrafted so and he will be in canton
someday so he at least deserves
honorable mention
yep absolutely right yeah romo undrafted
and and uh you know romo's not going to
make it to the hall of fame but it just
shows you can find a franchise
quarterback anywhere uh if you get lucky
and uh the cowboys got lucky with tony
romo but but you know what i
they knew he was going to be something
early on and sean payton tried to get
tony romo
as soon as sean payton became the head
coach of the saints in 2006 tried to pry
him away from parcells and parcells
wasn't having it because parcells knew
at some point that year blood sews to
the bench and tony romo becomes the
starting quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports